yo
who were you supposed to fight that
didn't end up happening
um
you were supposed to the last fight yeah
the last fight but that was supposed to
be the social club [ __ ] who are you
supposed to fight pnb Rock oh God damn
it that's right it was pnb Rock Rest in
Peace man that's [ __ ] up super [ __ ]
up
I totally forgot that dude yeah me and
him cool though that was that's why I
remember him
you're like yo we're cool as [ __ ] yeah
you made a whole song Together
everything I was trying to chop it up
with him about it like man let's just do
this
I don't know I think it was just some
business [ __ ] or something some end up
going down super sad situation man
obviously you live in LA and you know
it could have been you yeah I mean it
could have been anybody you know what I
mean like that's what I'm saying right
that's why I'm like
I'm about to dip when you see that kind
of [ __ ] like are you like how like I
mean you're I feel like you're a pretty
careful guy when I see you moving around
like and you're also not very um
you don't flaunt a lot you know what I
mean yeah
um do you move does it make you move
around even more careful does it make
you even more conscious of what what
your surroundings and yeah bro I'm like
I got my defensive awareness out here is
A1 I ain't gonna lie yeah you know what
I'm saying I just beef
I'm always paranoid yeah [ __ ] that [ __ ]
kind of ass but it's like yeah because
they're always paranoid it's like how
can you like when can you be comfortable
right because like
yeah man that's just sad bro that's
just wild I think this is kind of a
unpopular opinion but I just think
artists should move around with no
jewelry or they should wear fake [ __ ]
and I'm being serious like if you wore a
fake Rolex nobody would ever question
that you were wearing a fake Rolex
that's facts and you know it is very
effects like you know like uh you know
Chad Ochocinco the football player he
always would say I wear fake jewelry
because I'm putting my money into this
[ __ ] and nobody's ever gonna look at me
they I have the money to get the real
[ __ ] but if I get robbed or something
happens it's fake go ahead take it right
or if you don't have any jewelry you
just what are you gonna get away with an
iPhone that I'm gonna track and some
debit cards I'm gonna call and cancel
and like yeah so yeah I don't know man
it's I'm more so like I'm like a
collector though that's why I'll be
buying [ __ ] like I like collecting jury
and I'm like into watches and [ __ ]
what is uh besides jewelry do you
collect anything else like Pokemon cards
or [ __ ] obviously nah nah just
jewelry yeah I like collecting jury
and just like reselling and [ __ ] I'm
damn near like a low-key a jeweler damn
there
were you able to take advantage of the
watch Market spiking the way it spiked
during the pandemic and make some money
no because I didn't sell okay I held my
[ __ ] but I ended up buying I bought some
[ __ ] recently and I got up I'm like up
50 off already yeah cause for people who
don't know like any precious items
basketball cards watches things that are
like one of ones like hard carryable
things like or they [ __ ] watches went
nuts during the pandemic yeah crazy
three if you buy 350 400 it's crazy
stupid prices but I didn't sell
but you know it's because I like my [ __ ]
that I'll be buying so that's fair yeah
I'll be rocking it sometimes